euh le célèbre passe-partout a révélé le
passe-partout a un lien familier à
l'improbable cette semaine mais lequel
il est le neveu du Père Fouras il est le
fils du beau-frère de feindra bref ça
baisse quand même beaucoup euh non le
fort il sort avec la belle-mère de
passe-muraille il est cousin germain
Olivier Minne ah
ah
il sortirait avec la belle-mère de
passe-muraille alors on a les réponses
évidemment en images avec Jordan de luxe
je crois qu'il y a une histoire avec
votre compagne
et moi je suis avec la maman de la fille
c'est c'est énorme
vous l'aviez parlé d'une jolie blonde et
qu'il la connaissait c'est lui il était
à son appartement un jour je dis tiens
Anthony j'ai passé te voir chez toi
sur le balcon une géolée blonde d'accord
et j'appelle
jolie blonde il me fait ben c'est la
maman de ma femme d'accord il me fait tu
veux monter
tu veux venir en avait acheté bien sûr
et puis voilà c'est
ça c'est trop drôle donc tous les quatre
vous devez vous faire des sacrés sports
et avec toute la famille et alors on
voit on voit dans les décors de Jordan
qui ne comprend rien d'accord comme moi
je n'ai rien compris
passe-partout il sort avec la maman et
passe-muraille avec la fille hein
ne sont pas en famille donc ça ne marche
pas il y a aucune consanguinité dans
l'histoire ça marche il y a la mer
OK
[Rires]
drôle oui non juste préciser que c'est
une vraie belle histoire d'amour parce
que elle le suis partout quand on avait
reçu passe-partout sur ce plateau elle
était avec lui en loge et dans toutes
les émissions dans tous ses déplacements
elle est elle est avec elle et comme
Deluxe qui a démarré le lundi matin sur
C8 est un journaliste de fond
mais non on s'écrit tout le temps il
sait quand même
pour le coup on s'écrit tout le temps
elle a vraiment il le sait on est potes
dans une semaine et je sais rien qui va
me poser
la question qui a posé maintenant vous
allez voir je me suis dit quoi il était
chez lui le soir il s'est tient j'ai
écrit à mes questions comment celle-là
lui est venue parce que forcément ça
fait un petit peu scandale il a demandé
à pas se partout combien il mesurait en
téléphone portable si on les on les
additionne regardez
il est avec nous notre André nationale
pour terminer cette émission ils vont
relever le défi des iPhone petit clin
d'oeil Élodie Costa alors on le fait
j'ai un téléphone je vous en avez un
vous rendrez et voilà alors on y va
André vous dites que vous faites plus de
6 iPhone c'est ça plus le 6 oui 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 iPhone André je sais pas ce que
vous allez gagner le droit de revenir
toi un petit iPhone de plus que toi
[Rires]
Elodie Elodie Costa c'est une star de
Tik Tok qui a presque un million
d'abonnés qui a atteint de de la mise
oui qui est de petite taille et qui
avait lancé cette traîne de cette mode
de se faire mesurer en iPhone et elle
mesure ses iPhone il a voulu reprendre
la traîne de faire la même chose
sur Internet
moi aussi combien de tablettes surtout
ça serait gênant si lui était choqué ça
le fait marrer il rebondit là dessus
il y a des nains qui disaient mais
laissez-nous à te lancer mais c'est pas
qui voulait te lancer il voulait du
boulot ça intéresse personne qu'on jette
comme
si c'est un moyen d'avoir du boulot ça
va pas laisser les plus de boulot d'être
mesuré en iPhone a priori là Jordan
il sera réinvité on en parle ça lui fait
de la communication est-ce qu'il le fait
vraiment parce que ça lui plaît ou
est-ce qu'il le fait pour exister c'est
ça qui est vraiment dérangé exactement
est-ce qu'il ne s'est pas dit ça va me
faire un petit peu toutes les blagues de
ce type là aujourd'hui en fait on n'ose
même plus les faire même si on se dit
allez c'est pas touché mais en fait vaut
éviter moi c'est un peu compliqué
surtout quand tu sais que du coup Benoît
fait 9 donc 2 de plus seulement un
iPhone